how is saturday night live going to top
all the buzz over their season 46
premiere
as expected the show went all in on the
presidential debate and the coveted
crisis
and that did not sit well with everybody
but alec baldwin
is clapping back at his critics and you
did take the covet test you promised to
take in advance correct
absolutely scouts on it nobody thought
that they were
mocking somebody's illness rules are
meant to be broken
it's the same with masks i've got mine
right here in my pocket okay it's right
here
[Applause]
so if there was ever the suggestion that
trump was truly
gravely ill if they would have done
something else the china virus has been
very mean to me in
being a hoax and that statement is
something that i will
it'll probably come back to haunt me
later this week you only have
the wars of the white house itself and
if their word had been that he was in
serious trouble then we probably
wouldn't have done it
alec defended his portrayal of the
president in a 15-minute post on
instagram
but the covid controversy didn't hurt
snl's ratings
this weekend show was the most watched
season premiere in four years
and the second biggest in more than a
decade the star-studded show hosted by
chris rock
featured jim carrey as joe biden
[Applause]
and maya rudolph as senator kamala
harris america needs a whop
woman as president
i did hear the quote it was a smash hit
what was the scramble like behind the
scenes i think it was
chaos yeah yeah so i was just hearing
from some writer friends during the
moments that was happening
just how many jokes we're going to be
able to live cast members heidi gardner
and chris redd told me
that with the president in the hospital
as the live show unfolded
producers definitely felt a certain
pressure i also know that it's expected
of the show to address what's going on
in the world today
election years make stars are y'all
are you ready for your close-up yeah
bring on the close-up let's do this
yeah i'm embracing all of you man i love
it for the next five weeks
it gonna be crazy
you